another something completely different
[Applause]
50 years ago today the groundbreaking
British sketch series Monty Python's
Flying Circus premiered on the UK's BBC
one and forever changed the world of
comedies yes gangs of old ladies
comprised of Graham Chapman John Cleese
Eric Idle Michael Palin Terry Jones and
Terry Gilliam the troops absurd humor
was a subversive poke in the eye to
buttoned-up British society sketches
like the Ministry of Silly Walks the
dead parrot and the Spanish Inquisition
became comedy classics in an interview
for CBS this morning Saturday Idol
recalled those early days you really
didn't know what you were doing I hadn't
a clue but we knew what we didn't want
to do we knew we didn't want to be save
now a frontal nudity
[Music]
how was it received initially in britain
with massive indifference Monty Python's
Flying Circus ran for four seasons
before the BBC pulled the plug in 1974
but things were just beginning across
the pond that same year a Dallas public
television station started airing
episodes of Flying Circus soon other PBS
stations followed suit giving the
Pythons a big US following and that
brought the truth to Hollywood 1975's
Monty Python and the Holy Grail a spoof
of medieval film genre was a huge hit
every money Python movie has had a
similar sort of reception where they get
ok reviews they do OK at the box-office
and then people watch them and REE watch
them Andry watch them and they almost
seem to age like wine they don't get old
decades later it became a Tony
award-winning musical
wise look gone more films would follow
along with a stage film and comedy album
with Chapman's untimely death in October
1989 the rest of the troupe decided to
call it quits but their mark on comedy
was already made they found a way to
make very smart comedy about very silly
things or to treat very serious topics
in a very silly way and so that's one
reason why I think that their comedy has
endured just a fish food in 2014 the
surviving members reunited one more time
for the last night of the Pythons
in front of 15,000 fans at London's o2
arena and an estimated 50 million more
watching worldwide
[Applause]
and I am told that that song is the most
played at British funerals
according to British legend oh yeah
and Sony Depot there and yeah one of it
one of the one of the one of the great
quotes there I mean it's what we didn't
know what we were doing we knew what we
didn't want to do right right it's just
a flesh room that's cool to draw shall
we